let's go next to kate from denmark
denmark
one of my favorite countries kate you're
on the air
kate from denmark please unmute yourself
you are on the air but you do need to
understand
sorry um didn't realize um hello
hi it's been a while since i've listened
to so because i've been busy so i'm a
little behind
the news but i heard
that a new bill is perhaps
maybe being passed that will be
making it easier to do so to vote in
america
how have you heard about that one no i
haven't is this uh
this is a federal bill for what
automatic voter registration i know of
states that are doing this but i've not
heard of the bill you're talking about
kate
um something familiar to uh to it
it was supposed to make it easier uh
also
um what was it there was another thing
in the bill
is something like if you donate a
certain amount to small
um representatives it will
be matched up so if you
donate i think it was 10 or in
dollars it would be t17 at least it will
be
would be easier for smaller people like
democrats or black people and such
to actually have a chance instead of
just the big
representatives smaller people like
democrats or black people kate i've got
to tell you i don't know what you're
talking about but i will look into it i
can tell you that
yeah i just heard i'm not sure if it was
something solid but a
friend of mine mentioned that they heard
it on another new show
um all right i will look into that i
will look into that
how are things in denmark by the way
uh there are currently
as well as they can be we just had a
snow storm recently
okay uh but if it's corona
wise we're still on lockdown and it
looks like
it might be extended i see
and are you in are you in copenhagen or
are you elsewhere in the country
uh no i am in the [ __ ] and called uh
fiasco
did you say it's a car it's a commune
yeah um it's it is instead of state it's
called
kumuna in denmark ah okay but it it is a
commune am i understanding that
correctly
yeah and
and do you how is that do you like that
oh it's basically like a state like
denmark is
separate up in different uh
communes so the budget is easier to
handle because some
of farming lands and others are more
like big
cities like over so they need different
things
oh i see i think we're talking about so
you're not saying what i understand as a
commune is something else
okay i understand i understand yeah um
okay good well i
listen kate i appreciate the call i hope
to get back to denmark
as soon as it's safe yeah that would be
lovely have a nice
evening all right you too kate from
denmark
um great to hear from her